donald bonsoir claude blanchemaison
question comment la france a continué à
faire des essais même après
l'indépendance de l'algérie
tout simplement parce que c'était prévu
dans les accords d'evian conclu en mars
de 2 mai 1962 et ces accords prévoyaient
que pendant au moins cinq années
la france pourrait continuer à faire des
essais dans le sahara alors pourquoi y
at il eu cette clause qui au départ
était d'ailleurs secrète
et bien tout simplement parce que ça
n'était pas une priorité pour le fln
puis pour le gouvernement algérien
d'arrêter ces essais à l'époque il n'y
avait d'ailleurs pas de réglementation
internationale il n'y avait pas de
traité sur la non prolifération
nucléaire encore moins c'est venu
beaucoup plus tard de traité interdisant
les essais et puis on avait fait savoir
à la délégation qui négocie à evian que
la france avait fait quatre essais
atmosphériques entre 60 et 62 mais
qu'après l'indépendance elle se
cantonnerait à des essais souterrains et
qui sont évidemment moins en moins
polluant que pour l'environnement et
pour les populations qui peuvent être au
tour alors cela dit les français ont
remis donc en 87 l'ensemble des lieux
aux autorités algériennes
après avoir démonté d'installation mais
et par conséquent boucher aussi les
galeries ou été fait les essais
souterrains mais ils ont laissé
probablement un certain nombre de
véhicules d'équipements militaires dont
ont testé la résistance au souffle de de
l'explosion nucléaire et à certain
nombre de chars de d'équipements
militaires ont été enterrés dans le
sable et c'est ceci qui aujourd'hui fait
l'objet du contentieux dont vous avez
parlé à l'instant dans votre sujet mais
des équipes de l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie deviennent sont venus au
début des années 2000
on examine la situation ont établi un
rapport
et puis en 2007 lors d'une visite de
monsieur sarkozy il a été convenu
d'établir un comité conjoint franco
algérien qui existent et qui pour le
moment n'a pas à donner beaucoup de
résultats donc ce problème reste entier
et il doit évidemment être traité il est
pourtant eu la loi morin a voté en 2010
pour indemniser les victimes des essais
nucléaires pourquoi n'at-elle pas
bénéficier aux algériens vient alors la
loi morin qui a été adoptée en 2010 a
été amendée à s'attendre deux fois et
fait l'objet de beaucoup de
récriminations d'abord des organisations
de victimes françaises
parce que elle a institué un comité qui
est assez bureaucratique dans son
fonctionnement et qui semble-t-il n'a
jusqu'à présent admis qu'une douzaine de
dossiers éligibles sur environ 900
conduit à présenter
alors ça c'est pour les ressortissants
français
évidemment c'est encore plus difficile
pour les ressortissants algériens qui
théoriquement sont éligibles
mais comme on le dit dans le vocabulaire
fleuri de l'administration française au
qualifie les evs algérien qui habitait
dans ces zones de travailleurs des
indices alors puisqu'ils étaient
travailleurs des oasis
il n'avait pas réellement de domicile et
ils peuvent difficilement prouvé qu'ils
étaient dans ces villages à proximité
des essais au moment où les essais en
haut lieu
c'est trop compliqué pour eux et par
conséquent les dossiers n'arrive pas ne
parviennent pas à ce comité qui par
ailleurs est sans doute beaucoup trop
sélectif donc il faut probablement
modifier la loi morin ce sujet est à
peine évoqué par le rapport stora qui
est relativement discret sur le sujet
des essais nucléaires dans le sahara
alors cette nouvelle crise franco
algérienne je dirais même cette énième
crise
elle ne risque pas de mettre à mal tous
les efforts de repentance qu'ont
entrepris emmanuel macron importance et
c'est un vocabulaire un peu un peu
religieux qui vient peut-être d'ailleurs
de l'inquisition
il s'agit pas du tout de problème
religieux il s'agit de problèmes de
relations internationales et le problème
concret est ce que monsieur t bounadi
dans les différentes interviews qu'il a
données
ces derniers jours et notamment une
grande interview à une chaîne de
télévision dimanche dernier c'est qu'ils
avaient des problèmes concrets
et puis il ya des problèmes de mémoire
alors pour ce qui est des problèmes de
mémoire
il faut appeler les choses par leur nom
il n'y a pas d'évènement algérie il ya
eu une guerre d'indépendance
il n'y a pas eu des événements à sétif
en 45 ya eu des émeutes à sétif qui ont
fait un certain nombre de morts il faut
nommer les choses et ouvrir les dossiers
et écrire l'histoire comme elle s'est
déroulée
et puis les problèmes concrets celui du
sahara et de la contamination de
certaines populations en est un il y en
a d'autres par exemple l'accès aux
archives
pourquoi est ce que les chercheurs
français n'ont pas accès aux archives
algériennes
pourquoi est ce que les chercheurs
algériens n'ont pas accès aux archives
françaises
c'est aussi un autre problème concret
qui devra être résolue dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines ou dans les prochains mois
monsieur t boom s'est montré
relativement optimiste sur l'évolution
des relations entre la france et
l'algérie est dans le flou a eu des
paroles plutôt aimable pour le président
de la république française en disant
qu'il comprenait bien la situation qu'il
avait d'ailleurs déjà fait beaucoup de
pas en direction de l'algérie qu'il
avait reconnu qu' à l'époque de la
colonisation des crimes avaient été
commis et que par conséquent il il était
dans la dent lac dans une optique de
compréhension de la position algérienne
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il fallait
s'excuser pour une situation qui date
d'il ya maintenant beaucoup d'années
vous l'avait dit et pour des
comportements de
c'est grand père donc on en est là et
cela dira le ministre des moudjahidine
donc des anciens combattants a réclamé
que vous l'avez dit aussi dans votre
sujet que l'état major français donnent
les cartes d'enfouissement des matériels
qui ont été contaminés par ces
explosions et qui étaient là comme
témoin de la résistance des matériaux et
en effet je pense que ceci sera
probablement fait dans la période qui
vient
monsieur des moulins aussi ait été
jusqu'à évoquer dans cette interview
télévisée l'hypothèse d'un échange de
visites présidentielles entre la france
et l'algérie
dès que la situation la situation du
coup vite 19 permettra que cet échange à
très haut niveau puisse avoir lieu donc
il est aux pubs il est plutôt dans une
optique de réconciliation et dans le
fond suivant en cela l'exemple d'autres
pays comme le vietnam
ils n'ont jamais demandé des excuses et
qui on tourne depuis pas mal d'années
des rapports excellents avec la france
merci beaucoup claude la blanche maison
expert en relations internationales